welcome to the world of warcraft feature
overview for the WoW token in this video
I'll explain what Wow tokens are and how
you can exchange them with other players
for gold game time or battlenet balance
the WoW token is an in-game item that
allows players to simply and securely
exchange gold between each other they
can be purchased for real money from the
in-game store and traded to other
players for gold through a special
section of the auction house once it's
been sold it becomes soulbound and the
player who purchased it can redeem it
for game time or battlenet balance to
purchase a token to sell for gold you'll
need to log into world of warcraft and
then find the wow token on the in-game
store once you've purchased it it'll
appear in your inventory head to the
nearest auction house select the
auctions tab at the bottom and drag the
wow token from your inventory to the
auction house the auction house
interface will automatically switch into
one specialized for selling wow tokens
you'll see the amount of gold you'll get
for selling it as well as an estimation
of how long it will take to sell once
you've confirmed that you'd like to put
your wow token up for sale that amount
of gold is guaranteed regardless of the
amount it actually sells for later as
soon as it does you'll receive your gold
in the mail if you'd like to buy
battlenet balance or game time using
your in-game gold you'll need to go to
the Browse tab on the auction house and
click on wow token at the bottom of the
list you'll see the current market price
for WoW tokens listed there and the
option to buy one once purchased you
just need to collect it from your
mailbox and use the item from your
inventory then select whether you'd like
to use it for gain time or battlenet
balance
if your account is currently inactive
you'll have the option to purchase a WoW
token for game time directly from the
character select screen the wow token is
an easy and secure option for players
who would like to purchase some extra
gold from other players or would like to
pay for their Wow subscription pets
mounts and other Blizzard products using
gold you can find more information on
the official world of warcraft website
at world of warcraft com thanks for
watching and we'll see you in Azeroth